[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez moi je vous parle aujourd'hui
je parraine le premier cool et qui est
super intéressant si vous êtes gamer si
par exemple vous avez une pièce pour
venir jouer vous êtes devant un pc vous
allez devoir d'une petite barre de 100
pour venir ne soit pas forcément la
grosse bardot sont pour le salon pour
venir regarder un film pour me regarder
des séries le grosse barre de son pour
la maison non je sais vous présente une
barre de son un peu plus petit c'est la
yamaha c'est la src 20 ha et la src 20
elle est vachement intéressante qu'elle
est très polyvalente les vrais juifs je
me fais des petites intro en musique
comme ça directement que la barre de son
[Musique]
j'adore ça j'adore ça j'adore ça bon
j'arrête la musique comment vous allez
tout se passe bien pour vous aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous allez bien ça va pas
trop mal ça va bien ça mais plutôt bien
avec de la bonne musique avec une part
de son très très cool je discute avec
yann maia quelques temps ils disent
écoutez monsieur gros on a un truc qui
est vachement intéressant écoute
monsieur revanche tu toi qui as may
écoute monsieur brunswick est vachement
intéressante à une barre de son qui est
super et c'est pas la barre de son tel
qu'on peut l'entendre la barre de son
dans le salon pour le au cinéma avec un
son spatialisé 3d non c'est pas ça
ça c'est plus la barre de son vous allez
mettre chez vous comme je vous le dis
une fois de plus pour une chambre
pourquoi pas pour un bureau c'est le
deuxième espace de vie dans lequel vous
avez besoin d'une barroso parce que vous
voulez une très bonne expérience pour
moi ça c'est super pour le gaming vous
avez une course vous n'êtes pas dans une
chambre vous êtes dans un bureau dans un
deuxième espace et bien vous venez
prendre cette barre de son vous la poser
devant votre télé vous la poser devant
un pc pourrait venir jouer vous avez une
super expérience et ça je trouve ça
vachement bien et le deuxième un truc
qui est super intéressant avec ses vous
êtes dans une pièce par exemple et vous
n'avez pas de système audio
il n'ya pas venir utilisent cette barre
de son assaut glisse très facilement l
est pas très très grande en fait elle
fait quelque chose comme 60 cm de large
6 ennemis de haut elle est vraiment pas
très grande elle prend pas beaucoup de
place mais par contre elle vous
développe un son riche un son à la fois
claire avec des bases précises vous avez
intérieur de haut parleurs de 5,5 cm qui
développe 30 watts chacun et un caisson
de 60 watts avec un haut-parleur de 7,5
cm donc vous avez du son stéréo vous
avez un son spatialisé surtout pour
trouver des graves et ça j'adore attendu
de vous remettre un peu de musique là
regardez là
rendez vous compte avec la télécommande
je peux venir moduler et rajouter un
subwoofer tacos je coupe un peu au bout
ça c'est énorme
si vous aimez le son qui envoie un petit
peu de groupes comme ça c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment super comment utiliser
la barre de son comme une enceinte
connecté à la maison en bluetooth et
bien c'est très cool que vous
l'utilisiez pour brancher votre télé
votre pc en hdmi même en fibre optique
parce que vous avez deux entrées fibre
optique alors moi je les ai utilisés
dans différents univers pour jouer pour
la musique et dans tous les cas elle
fonctionne merveilleusement bien comme
ici on parle de d'objets connectés tout
ça fonctionne également avec une
application joue le monde dans quelques
instants
je vais vous faire faire un petit peu le
tour en fait elle est super simple
regardez vous allez petit voyant led qui
sont juste la mode télé mode optique
mode bluetooth analogique surround et
vous venez tout choisir tout petit votre
télécommande sur le dessus vous allez
retrouver dans votre petit logo yamaha
forcément ici vous choisissez votre
entrée on est sélectionné soutien à vous
monter son vous baissez le son vous est
allumée vous l'éteignez à l'arrière ici
c'est juste pour la mise à jour on s'en
fiche vous avez deux câbles optiques
juste là et là sur le côté là je pas si
vous le voyez à cause du câble à la
voilà ici vous avez du hdmi rcp en plus
venir à la fixer sur un mur si vous le
souhaitez directement et comme vous le
voyez c'est christine noir sur blanc
bien vous avez du dolby audio qui vous
développeurs sont super immersif sont
deux dimensions pas 3d mais qui marchent
vachement bien toi c'est la partie
hardware au niveau de votre barre de son
vous avez également une petite télé coq
est vachement bien bon vous l'allumez
vous éteignez vous choisissez votre
entrée clairement risques permettra de
dire détacher les son médium les voix
notamment lorsque vous écoutez quelque
chose vous avez un petit peu en main
bruit de fond eh bien vous appuyez sur
clermont se détachent les son médium se
détachent les fréquences des voix pour
bien comprendre ce qui se dit là vous
avez le bac ce basse extend basse ici là
qui vous permettra de booster un peu vos
basses et on se rend vraiment compte
comme ça pouvait régler également le
niveau de bassy siècle seuls bouffeurs
c'est vachement bien le niveau de
volumes bien évidemment ici
et puis vous choisissez ici stéréo
standard mobigame les modes en fait vous
l avoir et hop un petit muc là c'est
très simple et ça marche pas fort mais
surtout vous avez une application et ça
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle sambar
remote et voilà trouve vachement bien
parce qu'en fait c'est pareil elle est
très simple très intuitive regardez là
en fait en au juste là vous venez
choisir on va baisser un petit peu
je veux dire tout cas peu plus gai on à
se mettre autre chose en musique ça je
préfère ça donc pas chercher votre
rentrée je suis en bluetooth analogique
optique tv comme je souhaite sans
problème la gelée 1000e basses extrêmes
dit vous l'entendez large pas si vous en
rendrez compte parce que j'ai un petit
micro a des sags rouge croyez moi et
l'appareil de pierre boys qui vient
booster les fréquences médium donc là
vous choisissez et stéréo standard monf
latin classic movies san équaliseur en
fait un tout petit mais certaines
certaines fréquences et là vous avez
votre indicateur de l'aide
vous êtes et niveau l'aide moyenne forte
ouais enfin c'est l'idée vous l'avez
toujours sa main dans une chambre le
soir et vous voulez regarder un film
vous voulez pas voir la lumière qui
vient vous déranger eh bien regardez là
par exemple up que je me mets sur je
suis là vous voyez qui remet sur off
la led disparaît il faut un petit peu de
temps j'appuie elle revient aïe ça
rajoute un peu plus
voilà c'est un très grand classique
alors on a vraiment des fonctions bazin
ya rien devient complètement dingos là
dessus mais ce qui est là fonctionne
très bien après vous avez des
informations sur votre modèle où c'est
fort tu chantes forme ont émis quelques
informations sur votre version 6 et ça
provient la supprimer et c'est tout
c'est extrêmement simple
c'est génial alors moi j'aime beaucoup
l'idée une fois de plus pour venir faire
quelques petites parties de consoles à
la maison avec des amis vous le mettez
dans un coin ça me permet d'avoir de la
musique chez vous ça vous fait une
enceinte connectés en fait tout
simplement bluetooth
alors ici les collègues ça va être du
lbc ça va être dû à ses vrais du mp4
également vous n'avez pas ici
d'assistant vocalpad amazon alexa vous
n'avez pas de repli de paix qui coûte
299 euros voire un peu moins cher je
mets le lien en bas dans la description
aller jeter un coup d'oeil dessus pour
essayer de venir jeter une oreille moi
j'aime bien il avoue ne voyage pas si
vous en rendrez compte gimont
haut-parleurs qui planquaient là là et
j'ai le deuxième qui est là vraiment
pour avoir râlé on le voit là il se
dessine un peu là pour vraiment avoir la
stéréo et spatialisation de récupérer le
woofer par la grille que j'ai en dessous
ici en pour la petite histoire c'est pas
si vous savez y amasser l'inventeur de
la barre de son os ça c'est une
catégorie barre de son qu'il n'avait
plus qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
arrêté et qu'il reprenne un petit peu la
barre de son
deuxième barre de son en fait c'est
vraiment ce que comme ça que je le vois
grande barre de son pour votre télé
principal petit bar de son pour lier
mines petite part de son pour le pc pour
le redis ça j'aime bien cool et elle
fait un petit tuyau est pas très lourde
moi je voulais vous la présenter parce
que je ne suis pas intéressant pour une
deuxième pièce si vous êtes gamer je
sais pas encore si vous êtes gamer dites
le moi en commentaires si vous êtes un
gamer ça pour moi c'est un outil qui est
super intéressant parce que ça va venir
augmenter l'expérience au delà du fond
de votre télé pour une barre de son
écoute en un peu moins de 300 euros vous
venez vraiment augmenter expérience
avoir une expérience beaucoup plus
immersive avec un sont de bien meilleure
qualité surtout avec des masses qui
envoie qui tabasse donc ça j'aime
beaucoup ça vraiment super a vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce qu'une petite barre
de son comme ça pourrait vous tentez
hyper simple à connecter hyper simple à
utiliser avec un son qui est clair qui
est riche et qui fonctionne bien
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
barreau commentaire tant le retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler de
cake pareil d'audio peut-être pourquoi
pas d'ailleurs si dites moi ça pourrait
vous intéresser en bas en commentaire et
moi je vais mettre un petit peu de son
là pourtant le mans jahier pour terminer
cette vidéo écoutez ça
[Musique]
ça ronronne c'est énorme objectif à
terme est déçu
[Musique]